sitting beside kasparov and karpov that
is insane that is fantastic well these
two superstars the other pognation
magnus crawls in game two
now started and it is a young
progression with the white pieces david
that's right so we do see the spanish
opening uh an opening that both of these
players are extremely familiar with from
a young age and we do see a variation
called the open spanish where there has
been a trade of pawns in the center at
an early stage usually in the spanish
opening it's very blocked very congested
all the pieces all the pawns remain on
the board in the open spanish however
there tend to be more open lines so um
very classical stuff at the moment i
would ignore the computer bar um the
computer will not know as well as these
players right now who have rehearsed
these types of lines countless times
and this type of line is regarded as
being slightly better for white
um it's very forcing as well normally
play
is well analyzed up until move 20 even
30
so it's a memory test at this early
stage and normally that's not what what
uh magnus carson is about it's not
normally what he goes for yeah and this
is actually a big favorite of shakira
mama jaroff's a player that we saw
compete in the preliminaries and uh yeah
he's the big champion of this variation
and you're right
no games by carlson
well i just have to jump in and say so
very different tempo in the two
semi-finals there so these two players
the first game lasted for an hour they
now just started their second game but
anish geary and wesley so they're
already in game three first one ending
up with a win for wesley so second one
was a draw and now they're playing their
third game and we do know that in each
gary needs a win in one of the two last
games to tie
the first match
yeah um i'm not a huge fan of wesley
so's approach in that last game wesley
had white after winning the first game
with black but wesley he just went
straight for a draw forced to draw out
of the opening and um frustrating for an
issue yeah frustrating for anish but
wesley's banking on the fact he will
stay unbeaten in those next two games
usually i found from my own experience
that the chess god kaiser she punishes
you if you head for quick draws with
white um every time i make a quick draw
with white i always get punished in the
next game with black so let's see if
wesley so
um can continue his good form in that
next one and ishkiri trying to fight
back
all right well i guess it is with the
white pieces jana pognyacci also is sort
of looking to surprise magnus although
this
sort of was a very solid opening that
both players will be very known with
yeah the last couple of moves they're
not familiar to me but maybe they have
been seen in the past we have seen a
queen trade that's the most important
thing and now white had created a huge
threat if we bring up the analysis board
we can see
in this position where the queens have
disappeared black has just brought his
knight to the edge of the board with an
idea black wants to capture this
important pawn this isolated pawn and
therefore napoli actually created a
threat of his own he brought his bishop
forward
creating a pin here hitting this black
knight which is actually hard to defend
black had to play the very awkward move
to retreat his bishop defending this
knight and now um there's a bit of
choice but white has to be quick because
he's still facing this threat knight
takes pawn would now actually fork the
rook and the bishop um so the first move
i was looking at i'm not sure if it
works the first move i wanted to play
was rook takes bishop eliminating the
defender of this knight forcing the
black king out into into the open but
maybe there's just no follow-up you can
give a check for example the black king
steps back and you can bring your bishop
back creating this idea again but black
will simply step forward and this would
just repeat the position um
i'm i'm trying to see a follow-up for
white here it feels as if black's
position is so loose so shaky with this
king out in the open this night
vulnerable but maybe there's just no way
to take advantage and that's why the
pontiac is having a think now yeah
and uh in the meantime i do have to show
you that magnus has received a challenge
on twitter from john carlo it says a
little bit of a different opponent today
i think he can take magnus and there he
is with his pet rabbit
isn't that the cutest that he's very
cute
and uh abraham ibrahim
says even the son is scared of world
champion ignoring his focused eyes and
is referring back to the first game when
the sun just shone
and gave him a kind of a super
superstar appearance yeah that's right
definitely look like it but it's getting
late in oslo where magnus is sitting yes
so the sun is going down and
if you'd like to send us your pictures
we absolutely love receiving them you
can use the hashtag tag chess champs and
join in the fun joining the conversation
the more the merrier we absolutely love
it
yeah that picture with the sun in
magnus's eyes now in my head i keep
singing that song the sun always shines
on tv and it's just no
you don't you don't know that song huh
is that like a har isn't it yeah it is
like
i must admit when i first moved to
norway i only knew one song from aha
which was like a take on me you're like
every brit knows that song and uh
somehow i got educated
[Laughter]
he's an interesting man morton harkett
and uh meanwhile napoli actually he is
in the tank he is thinking um from his
body language he's
i mean to me at least um he's hinting at
the fact that he has indeed studied this
position before from the white side but
he just can't remember what he has
studied and that is psychologically a
difficult hurdle to overcome
um knowing that you are familiar with
the position but not quite uh grasping
the key ideas or recalling the key ideas
um at least and if that's the case then
napoli actually he just needs to find a
path to just continue the game or or
maybe even go for that repetition of
moves that i mentioned a few moments ago
um you can't get to a situation where
you're beating yourself up in your mind
about not remembering and end up kind of
watching that spiral out of control okay
so i like ruth takes bishop is a really
forcing kind of the game will end in a
draw in a matter of moves but can you
play something normal like for instance
defend the pawn now i'm not necessarily
thinking of moving the bishop because i
think the bishop would actually get in
the way of the rook so i mean can you
just go i'm going to move my rook two
squares forward
pawn is defended
we
let's play
um yep so instead of rotate bishop which
is the most forcing move the other
option is to bring your rook up
sides
defend this pawn to the side and um the
issue here for white is that suddenly
the pieces are maybe a bit clumsy and
for example if black just castles the
king um to this side of the board the
pin is broken this rook in the corner is
no longer
a target suddenly all of black's pieces
coordinate and
how are you gonna get your pieces into
the game for white especially these two
guys they're not partaking in the action
and all of black's pieces um look pretty
good
um okay still pretty much in the balance
but um for example if white brings the
bishop out um i could definitely imagine
a scenario where black starts to
activate this rook maybe open things up
a bit later on and i think magnus carson
will be very happy in this type of
queenless middle game where he tends to
thrive um so as your vanco mentions it
is possible in this position to bring
the rook up defend this pawn or
step the bishop forward and defend this
pawn but either way um it feels like
it's losing a bit of momentum and uh
magnus would have time to finish his
development so what would you do here uh
david would you respect your opponent's
idea or would you kind of go okay fine
the opening didn't work so well for me i
got caught in some preparation
uh well there's our answer you can see
let's check out the players cameras um
will we see a repetition of moves and a
draw the position repeating itself
it looks like they're out of here um
whoa and it is a draw it is a draw
three-fold repetition same position
three times on the board neither side
could actually escape that at the end
and
a short but tense draw